wo liegt dann die zukunft der union arid
u
und jetzt live aus dem bundestag in
berlin das große cd okay friedrich merz
ist für eine frauenquote wenn uns zitat
nichts besseres einfällt frage da
verhält gesagt ja
ist eigentlich schon es sollen gerade
das macht für minister außenpolitik als
tralala politik also wirklich eine
schöne aussage ja das ist eine gute
aussage ich finde das spricht für die
qualität also wenn du eine frau wäre
würde ich sagen komm zu mir nach hause
welcher cdu politiker ist älter
friedrich merz
ist alt aber aber nicht so
ja eindeutig philipp antwort es ist
tatsächlich so dass das von der
wissenschaft noch nicht abschließend
geklärt werden konnte
was sollte denn auf einem bierdeckel
stehen aber natürlich bier alles andere
wäre kompletter schwachsinn oder die
steuererklärung
hier spielt er jetzt da auf den
neunziger auch an der friedrich merz man
diese idee sondern dass ich bereit bin
mich daran ja wie fanden sie die
weltfremd fasst friedrich merz ist
weltfremd
was passiert statistisch gesehen zuerst
das waren oma und opa wird oder b dass
man das durchschnittsalter eines cdu
mitglieds erreicht oma und opa
goldrichtig 52 jahre und
durchschnittsalter als cdu mit 60 8
jahre dies ist bei der fdp eigentlich
ich weiß nicht wie ist denn euer also
das schmeiße ich sehe dass
leistungen was es geht wirklich nur um
leistung ja anscheinend aber warum ist
wolfgang kubicki dann noch mitglied
wolfgang kubicki geleistet auch was aber
er leistet sich für blödsinn
was ist das modernste an friedrich merz
seine neue brille oder b
viele menschen verlieren ist überhaupt
nicht mehr noch nicht mal die bringen
der nicht einmal die brille wo ich
wirklich dankbar bin ist dass sie den
und 16 jahre vom hals gehalten hat wie
hoch ist der frauenanteil in der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
a50 die union die volkspartei
schlechthin ist und deswegen beide
geschlechter nicht mehr haben eins gibt
er mir frauen auf der welt es müssten
eigentlich 1 50%
23,5 prozent erscheint mir aber auch
sehr hoch haben sie gerade unsere fragen
kritisierte zimmermann heinrich dürfen
sie niemanden den quizmaster kritisierte
aber bisher nicht
- aus zwei punkte
was kann man in einem ganz normalen jahr
schon mal verlieren seinen
haustürschlüssel
wer sein portemonnaie c ca 15.000
mitglieder
der cdu sondern 120 alles passiert also
das mit dem haus the station dem
portemonnaie wissen wir nicht aber am
laufen hat sich ja so tolpatschig
angestellt im wahlkampf dass es
wahrscheinlich ist zumindest
hochland stehen bleiben sie hier wer
sind die sind gleich auch noch gefragt
ja oder sie kommen spontan dazu wir
kommen da kommen sie doch dazu da machen
wir jetzt hier im duell kommen sie nie
mit das ist doch dass noch jemand
sexuell und jetzt geht's los warum ist
die cdu keine coole verteilte junge
leute hey wieso wir haben doch philipp
am tor b stimmt
oder b ja stimmt wir haben philipp am
tor
der autor ist ja nur ein synonym für die
jugend heraus strahlt sie sind ja die
jungs sie finden nicht fresh empfangen
ist also sind die jungs die wir schon
für meinen sport gekündigt werden in
seiner eigenen mannschaft wir sind aber
heute auch
konrektor aus dem parlament ist und sie
finden sie sich nicht so sicher sobald
die linke mal wieder über 3 prozent das
machen wir auch das große linken bis
jetzt sind sie uns richtig verstehen
was ist peinlich ja eine bundestagswahl
gegen die spd zu verlieren oder b ein
signal des aufbruchs senden indem man
einen 66 jährigen mann der neunziger zum
parteichef macht jetzt antwortet du
meist ihr habt ja so abgeräumt gerade
nicht entstehen ja ist aber so ist noch
nicht abgearbeitet ich würde sagen wie
wichtig sind auch viele täter
ausgeschlossen ist schon bitter da
glaube ich habe aus bayern systems
bayern stimmt einfach gegen die esten
verloren
wenn leute kriegen aber auch noch in
bayern noch den ball wieder ins spiel
gebracht jedes mal wenn leute markus
söder dessen kriegen sie konnte
wir kommen zum thema frauen sind sie da
sattelfest
es kommt darauf an in welchem gebiet
frauen sind die
politischen
rechte zurück wenn von wahl zu wahl
circa eine million unionswähler schlicht
versterben wo liegt dann die zukunft der
union an riedhof was er wissen sich
unsere antworten haben sie das rote
licht
welcher cdu-landesverband wird von einer
frau geführt
rheinland-pfalz thüringen oder c
natürlich keiner so einen wichtigen job
kann man ja keiner frau überlassen
julia klöckners habe ich zurückgetreten
das neue christiane lieberknecht wir
haben jetzt eine stellvertretende
generalsekretär nicht bedenken ja
beispielsweise auch ein neues gesicht
beim thema frauen na ja das ist so bei
dem rechen cdu ladan und in der fdp
sieht die frauenquote und nicht so viel
besser aus aber da einfach abhauen
kommen wir waren auch im nahkampf
schluss
wusste früher weg der fährt mit dem
neuen euro ticket nach hause und braucht
17 stunden von mir noch kurz der hinweis
bevor madrid geht abonniert den youtube
kanal das spart wertvolle zeit beim
suchen von geilen content macht es wie
ich
so eine pfeife naja